aujourd'hui c'est le trentième
anniversaire de mon jeu les gamer et
disent qu'on est rétro il insistera du
bien ça veut dire qu'on est des vieux
mais qu'on écoule votre nom lara croft
votre nom ralph la casse dans mon jeu
c'est moi le méchant mais j'ai plus
envie d'être un méchant moi je vais
gagner une médaille
tu as déjà vu un méchant gagner une
médaille
c'est quoi tous ces trucs qu'ils veulent
ralph a abandonné son jeu il est celui
qui casse le projet est cassé nous
serons mis hors service pour demander
tout seul
tu serais pas ma gabon non pourquoi pas
un centime construisant grosse je sais
pas mais pourquoi es tu si
monstrueusement agacera vantomme toi tu
veux tu as mis dans un mois je me serve
à coup je me demande à moi de te rendre
service wright moquant
les belles histoires
celui bad est plus que grave certes dans
notre régiment
donc en fait tu sais pas conduire c'est
sympa au sens strict du devis kouao
ouais c'est pas si une pirouette un
petit tour de magie
youpi j'ai gagné la coupe
le magic a quasiment fait péter toute la
montagne a remarqué tazi